assume that a sharp edged type of
orifice is being used to drain a 6ft
tall storage tank that contains water
and is completely full the outlet of the
tank is open to the atmosphere the
orifice is flow coefficient CV is
0.98 and the coefficient of contraction
cc is
0.62 the orifice is 2T in diameter and
its invert is 1T above the bottom of the
tank what is the discharge out of the
tank in
CFS
so this is another problem that we'll
solve for flow rate using the equation
that includes the discharge coefficient
of an orifice we can see that we are
given the flow coefficient CV and the
coefficient of contraction
CC but really we need
CD however we can find that easily
either calcula it from CC *
CV or pulling CD directly from the
reference
manual the second Factor we need to make
sure we get correctly is H the height of
the fluid above the
orifice this is going to come from the
height of the water in the tank the
height of the orifice in the tank and
the center line of the orifice based on
the orifice diameter so let's get
solving so our equation for the
discharge using the coefficient of
discharge
is Q
equal
CD time the area of the orifice time the
square < TK of 2 * G *
H so
first we need to pick the
correct
CD so going to page 323 of the reference
manual we can see that a sharp edged
type
orifice has a
CD of 0.6
one and two is the
orifice
height so the orifice height as we wrote
out here we can draw real fast just to
make sure this makes sense
so if this is 1 foot above the bottom
and the orifice let's make that a little
bigger
is 2T
in
diameter and the height of the water is
5 ft and the center line through the 2T
orifice
is well 2 / 1 it's going to give us one
oh sorry that's 6 foot tall not
five 6 feet so we would have 6 feet
minus 1 foot minus
2 over two wow I really not getting my
denominators correct today okay
anyway that's going to give us H =
4T and now all we have to do is plug all
of our known into the equation so we can
say Q
equal
0.61
times the area of the orifice let's
calculate that real fast AO
= PK D ^2 over 4
=
Pi 2 ft^ squared over 4
equal
3.14 ft squared
so
3.14 fet
squared times I can already tell I'm
going to take up too much space so let
me just move that
down time the square < TK of 2 *
32.2 feet per second
feet per second
squared
times 4 feet for our
height and if we calculate this out we
should get a flow rate of about
3.74 feet cubed per second or
CFS and that's closest to our answer of
31 here now depending on if we had
picked another CD by accident or had
incorrectly calculated for a different
height we may have gotten one of these
other answers so those were the two
things that were important in this
problem and the rest of it was just a
simple calculation once you had those
figured out and that's it